[Music]  maybe it's time Olivia  [Music]  [Applause]  it's time with you  [Music]  takes luck to change main pillar digs  love to try  [Music]  you know man in the old days I always  knew like you were gonna do something  that you'd be alright it's the first  time I worried about you  [Music]  can I ask you a personal question  okay tell me something  do you write songs or anything I don't  sing my own songs why I just don't feel  comfortable why won't you feel  comfortable almost every single person  has told me they like the way I sounded  but that they didn't like the way I look  I think you're beautiful  Hey what I just want to take another  look at you in all the good times I find  myself  [Music]  bojay  we're going to get become sing that song  but I love no I can't do that  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  with  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  you